our
london town a modern metropolis
built on history and prosperity
only took 12 000 years to build it up
and
one night to tear it all down
oh my god listen up
get all your units to move in and lock
down the city
with london under attack by a mysterious
terrorist
the government turns to a private
military company called albion to keep
everyone safe what could possibly go
wrong
ladies and gentlemen mr nigel cass ceo
of albion he's kindly stepped up to
establish order
understand this i will not allow anyone
not even myself to jeopardize this
he will stop at nothing to permanently
control the city
london will be the first city in the
world to be made truly safe
nigel's not the only opportunist who's
taken a liking to this fair city
meet mary kelly head of the most
powerful crime syndicate in london
be sure and spread the word she and her
goons are using the dark web to sell
everything from party pills to people
this microchip is scary i know but i got
to keep tracks on my merchandise tonight
you made me a slave do not want to
ruffle her feathers
with the city out on its ass it now
falls on you
to build a resistance and take back
london
all right everyone faces on guns out
any of the brave londoners you see
walking the streets
can be recruited into your team
like him huh
or even huh
everyone could become your next secret
weapon
in our first mission we need to get some
dirt on nigel
cass and that means breaking into albion
headquarters
inside the tower of london all the hardy
souls you see here
are people we have recruited from the
streets of london
they all have unique abilities and
you're free to tackle this mission
with whoever you like dick got my eyes
finally zip up get to work and let's
never talk about this again
[Music]
like everyone in dedsec arthur can hack
pretty much
whatever but as a construction worker he
has a particular set of tools that make
him
handy
he can even call his own cargo drone
perfect for gate crashing when you're
not invited
and who needs a regular old gun when you
have a bloody nail gun
come here [ __ ]
jesus christ what is that thing perhaps
we could approach this mission
differently
if you'd rather keep your distance we've
got you covered
amy is a drone expert
what have we here a real tech
connoisseur
[Music]
hate spiders but love this one
what an adorable creepy crawler
here we are let's class the place up a
drone expert does have the unique
ability to summon their own drone
this little darling is fast and stealthy
i'm reading incoming drones
she can also hack enemy drones turning
the tide in her favor
and if you are not into direct
confrontation there are more ways than
one to get the job done
[Music]
recruiting an albion officer like
brielle here might be challenging
but it'll get you inside restricted
albion areas
don't mind me just doing recon for a
bunch of insurgents
however do anything suspicious and
she'll probably wind up with a bullet in
the back of her head
you've been approved
we're missing the human element here i
can get the defense minister on the line
right now if you feel you must
[Music]
criminals running our streets illegals
threatening our families the police
commissioner himself
assassinated by terrorists well that
seems to be enough evidence
next up we're crushing mary kelly's
organ farming operation and putting a
stop to it that's good
the fires expect high quality stuff
and we need a hard knot for this
impairing our frontal lobe again are we
rags don't disturb me in my natural
habitat
say hello to mickey the man lives for
his team
that put another air on the chest and
doesn't mind getting his hands dirty
he does have a slight drinking problem
though
he's passed out ah we'll we'll come back
to him
[Music]
you know what let's go with someone a
bit more professional
it's almost crass to call him a hit man
some might even call him an artist
[Music]
here's the bastard responsible
done and dusted not bad not bad if i do
say so in it
not everyone in london is a legendary
assassin or a super spy
but everyone can be a hero
so get out there find the best recruits
and build your resistance
it's time to take back london
[Music]
you